I have struggled with part bird for years. I used prilosec for years. I realized prilosec was
treated. It was only approved for maximum of 30-day use. I used prilosec for years until I
learned better and asked the doctor for another solution. I have been using pepsin for several years.
Okay, so what did I say a good doctor should do? Okay, this is, I'm just being facetious maybe,
but I think a good doctor needs to ask a simple question. Why does the patient have heartburn? Does the
patient have heartburn? Because they have a deficiency in prilosec? Oh, well, prilosec is not good
for us. Well, let's give them pepsin. I don't think you have heartburn because you have a deficiency
in pepsin. I don't mean to be mean, but this is the wrong thing to do. This is the wrong way to treat
disease because it's not treating disease. It's covering up symptoms. I've said it for, you know,
decades. It's like, okay, my car, my colleague, Jeepers, the check engine light is coming on. So when
I do is take a piece of black electrical tape and I got to put it right over that blasted light
because it bothers me. No, no, I don't see the light anymore. About that fixed. I'm going to keep
private my car. Okay, that's silly stupid, right? That I don't mean to be mean, but this is the way
we have been taught by our medical profession to treat disease. Has it? Okay, so heartburn, okay,
is a side of what? Heartburn is a side of decreased hydrochloric acid production. Period. I mean,
if you have heartburn, you definitely have a decreased hydrochloric acid production by the
final cells of your stomach. Okay, what does that lead to? By the time you already have heartburn,
you probably already have had a decreased hydrochloric acid production for probably months.
And you probably already have what can be a major, major cause of cancer is a major, major cause of
cardiovascular disease. And it is what? H. Pylori overall. So helicomacter pylori is the most
prominent, most common bacterial infection worldwide. It is the number one cause of stomach cancer,
causes multiple other cancers and it's top five cause of cardiovascular disease.
So it is a bad guy. So if you have had heartburn for years, you don't need to do an H. Pylori test.
You know that it's present. So you need to, I have a whole bunch of this, okay? So look at this
blog and that will help you the most. I actually have multiple blogs on H. Pylori with some
different videos on it. So that will help you. So that's the particular podcast that you could look at.
H. C. L. with your meals is the best thing to do. But some people that have had this for years,
they try taking H. H. C. L. and it really hurts their stomach. Well, that's a sign that they have a
really damaged stomach cells, possibly already ulceration. You need to switch back to
taking apple cider vinegar for a period of time with your meals. Oh my gosh, that hurts too. I can't
even take apple cider vinegar. Then you need to heal the stomach with deglycerized liquorice. I have a
whole protocol in that blog post that will help. Certainly if you need to chat with me,
I'll gladly talk to you through that as well. But dealing with H. Pylori is so, so important.
The main treatment nutritional product for H. Pylori is the, is um, um, the burberry,
is your, is your main nutritional killer of H. Pylori garlic works really well too. Um,
that's why I, that's why that's one of the reasons why burberry is one of my absolute favorite supplements
hands down. Um, and is because you know, you know, cancer is super common, right? But heart disease
is even cometer or someone. It's even more common. And um, never one killer in America is heart disease,
cardiovascular disease. And it is, you know, H. Pylori is a major player in that. Um, and H. Pylori is a
major player in cancer. So if you can keep that back down, you're better. We can do.